bien donc voici le film de monsieur
maurice claval monsieur maurice claval
ce que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
à votre film j'ai beaucoup de choses a
ajouté mon film tout de suite
tout de suite j'ai je m'adresse au
public et je lui dis ceci je viens de
rédiger la déclaration à l'instant le
film que vous venez de voir a été
censuré par la télévision française
peu importe qu'il était est censuré d'un
mot d'une phrase d'une séquence d'un
tiers des trois quarts d'un centième
c'est le principe même de la censure qui
est épouvantable abominable et invivable
en tout cas pour ma part je n'ai jamais
pu vivre ni écrire ni parler sous le
régime de la censure on m'a prévenu dans
l'après midi de cette coupure comme
opéré de cette chose inouïe et j'ai
élevé une protestation solennelle mais
cette chose inouïe j'attendais de
l'avoir pour la croire
je les ai vus en conséquence je viens de
prendre la décision suivante je ne serai
prendre part un débat qui commence sous
le régime de la censure
quelle qu'en soit la victime moi ou
monsieur royer il soit bien entendu
monsieur royer je ne me dérobe pas à une
confrontation entre nous sur le problème
des mères et de la culpabilité de la
société je vous propose de la reprendre
sur n'importe quelle chaîne de radio
libre s'il en existe et si évidemment
vous renoncez à la censure dont vous
constatez ici le désastre quant au
peuple français auquel je viens très
modestement de lancer un appel au
soulèvement de la vie contre ces espèces
de morts que sans la censure et autres
fascisme jose non - modestement lui
donner rendez-vous pour bientôt dans la
liberté pour la liberté
messieurs les censeurs bonsoir
je crois qu'il faut tout de même ajouter
à ceci un mot d'explication
monsieur maurice clavel viens de le dire
lui-même c'est une décision qu'il a
prise à l'instant et dont naturellement
nous ignorions tout jusqu'à cet instant
il y à une seconde précision je crois a
ajouté c'est que la censure dont il a
été question concernait le film de
monsieur maurice clavel ce film que vous
venez de voir mais je crois qu'à propos
de ce film on peut ajouter deux choses
première chose il me semble que ça
n'était pas un film qui portait en lui
même la marque d'une censure
particulièrement lourde
deuxièmement que la censure dont il a
été question concernait un mot un seul
mot à propos du président de la
république et à propos d'une
interprétations qui étaient faites d'une
interview donnée par le président de la
république
faute de combattants il est évident que
l'émission ne peut pas se continuer mais
il est normal qu avant de rendre
l'antenne du n'osions naturellement la
parole à monsieur jean royer qui comme
nous ignorait tout de cette affaire et
qui va pouvoir nous donner sa réaction